[Applaudissements]
alors on va jouer vous allez jouer tous
contrefaçon d'accord bon alors premier
jeu il y avait plein de jeux dans le
bigdil bill est ce que tu peux nous
expliquer le premier jeu c'est pas ça
qui va animer pradet mans séries le mon
ami vincent le premier lieu s'appelle la
montagne de sucre ap
le but du jeu est d'empiler sur un seul
morceau de sucre le plus de sucre
possible attention vous ne pouvez pas
jouer si vous êtes allergique au gluten
tu peux poser comme je veux quand tu
veux et le building
il faisait 11 millions de
téléspectateurs accident et j'adore
ouest ans à venir on a la pression c'est
pas d'aller trop vite
vous connaissez bien valérie et vincent
ouais ouais on a un peu bricolé chevy
chase et ouais ouais ouais la perceuse
c'est à toi à toi je sais plus quelle
émission on avait fait on avait fait la
millième on avait fait pas mal de choses
ça peut durer un à l'ehess
je vais rajouter un autre cadeau parce
que comme c'est très long je vais
rajouter en plus si tu gagnes tu as dit
valérie à la diva son corps ajoute une
machine à café steegen 1 à elle est là
on l'a dévalée valérie aller c'est bien
allez vas-y allez y a plein voilà on est
là qui va gagner entre vincent et kelly
comme vincent dont le speed mouchoirs
jong-il on dirait pas comme ça mais
c'est très dur de vider une boîte de
mouchoirs en papier
le premier qui arrive gagne le jeu
attention vous ne pouvez utiliser qu'une
seule main oui on doit on doit avec une
salle on doit on doit impérativement
enlevez vos choix un parent et tu peux
préparer le premier deux attaques
mais une bête voilà la réforme parce
qu'elle a tellement pleuré
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
e
elle élabore des civils benjamin et
géraldine un truc s'était jamais vu un
aussi bon dans les jets tous et bon dans
cette émission
[Applaudissements]
le but du jeu est de former entre deux
personnes la plus longue file de
canettes
on la suit les canettes une par une les
premiers qui font tomber leurs canettes
sont éliminés il les a gardés
j'ai quand même un lac salé premier du
fait tomber les canettes les prêts à
leiria comprend alors le jeu les
canadiens avec qui on joue 20 qui
appelait alors le but du jeu il est très
simple on se met face à face dans nos
équipes ont mis une première canette
comment attention je le promets qu'il
fait tomber la carène la peur du diable
alors on joue avec des canettes vides à
l'époque
ah oui bah oui non joue avec des canapés
ces passeurs de paris c'était bien
quoique c'est bien on ne touche pas
d'accord en fait j'en ai un qui bouge
pas et ne bouge
je sens qu'on va bien vas-y attend on et
comment là on est comment vois tu sais
pas bien c'est pas bien eh bien non et
oui on est deuxième mouture pour
l'instant au début un vrai recul pense
pas pour l'instant du mal tu bouges et
oui oui d'accord ok des grands débuts
ratés pas bien chez moi ça s'appelle un
métier nos territoires
benjamin hué normalement
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]